what up Internet my name is Nancy and
today imma be walking around the
BuzzFeed office trying to see if my
coercion I say my last name how long
have we been friends um almost two years
a little over a year for a good half a
year would you say that we're like good
friends yeah yeah we're good friends we
hang I've been to your house
do you know how to pronounce my last
name no n-no I don't want to try cuz I
feel like I'm gonna mess it up its new
year I had a friend in high school a
named Julian Ian it's not Wayne no its
new way it's still wrong I feel like I
just like blew your mind I've been
saying new new n since like middle
school when alright I don't like that
win it's actually wing wing wing oh I
don't want to try again
wait Wang Wei it's wing what can you
come closer and say it again Wayne Wayne
did you say anyway now I want to crawl
into your mouth to figure out where
where you're holding the word waiting
wing that's actually good so the thing
about the Vietnamese language is that
it's a monosyllabic language so every
single word is only one syllable so wing
is one word
so nu win is not correct a lot of the
sounds that goes into my last name
doesn't really exist in English language
Nancy told me how to pronounce her last
name last year and my dentist has the
same last name and I was able to call
her dr. win and I could tell it it meant
a lot to her that I said her name her
last name correctly Thank You Nancy I've
heard my last name butchered in so many
different ways that nothing really fazes
me anymore
we're all learning today
[Music]
not really me but definitely a lot of
other people are I'm really sorry you
can see it's okay we're still good
friends you want a hug yes
[Music]